thomas kneisel sie polarisieren immer
wieder mit beiträgen zur ukraine jetzt
geht es um das thema waffenlieferungen
naja also zunächst mal vorab ich bin
kein gegner des militärs und ich bin
kein pazifist ich bin trotzdem gegen
waffenlieferungen deswegen weil ich der
meinung bin sie sind erstens gefährlich
sie sind kontraproduktiv und sie sind
wahrscheinlich auch unnötig sind
gefährlich deswegen weil glaube ich
einigkeit darüber besteht dass
russland diesen krieg militärisch
jedenfalls nicht verlieren wird oder
will heißen genauer gesagt dass die und
kleine diesen krieg militärisch nicht
gewinnen kann weil das liegt einfach
daran dass die russland ist eine
atommacht russland ist natürlich
materielle der ukraine haushoch
überlegen wenn wir die ukraine jetzt mit
allen waffen versorgen die sie anfordert
dann wird es diesen krieg in die länge
ziehen wird die zerstörung ein noch
größeres ausmaß annehmen dann wird der
blutzoll auf beiden seiten weiter
steigen und das land zerstört werden die
zahl der flüchtlinge steigen ist immer
schwieriger werden ich bin auch nimmt es
gelänge die russen an den rand einer
niederlage
zu bringen dann ist die gefahr glaube
ich nicht von der hand zu weisen dass
ein diktator wladimir putin dem er viele
realitätsverlust attestieren dass der in
der tat auf den roten knopf drückt und
einen eine taktische antonia verkündet
ein szenario das nicht politisch für
unverantwortlich halten würde ich als
für kontraproduktiv einfach deswegen
auch weil wir müssen ja sagen was wollen
wir den langfristig wir wollen ja
irgendwann eine stabile friedensordnung
kam und die wird in der ukraine sollte
den natürlich platz greifen ohne dass
die territoriale integrität der opfer
und keine gefährdet wird dann ist die
ukraine aber ein florales ein ethnisch
ein kulturell ein sprachlich und
religiös florales land dann müssen die
einzelnen
bevölkerungsteile wieder aufeinander
zugehen können wenn wir jetzt diesen
krieg weiter befeuern dann stellten wir
auf der einen seite und chemische
nationalisten auf der anderen seite
russische nationalisten also eine beides
parteien putin der jetzt wir stellen die
staatliche oder die die nationale
identität der ukraine in frage es gibt
in der ukraine auch leute die das land
in trophy zieren wollen je länger der
krieg dauert desto mehr wird diese
radikalen kräftige stelle stelle mir das
gerade
thomas kneisel mit frau und fünf kindern
in seinem haus von unten kommen
einbrecher wollen also das wohnzimmer
belagern wurde also es ist erdgeschoss
belagert thomas gesagt ich ziehe mich
nach oben im ersten stock zurück damit
die einbrecher nicht noch weiter
vordringen die dringen also weiter vor
und dann räumen sie sozusagen auch den
ersten stock das weisen letzt die
einbrecher könnt ihr gerne als ihr
ausland er war selber aufnehmen in reval
sie war meine konflikt keine ausländer
langsam mal davon aus die ukraine stellt
die kampfhandlungen ein und wladimir
putin würde das ganze land erobern
glauben sie wirklich dass putin damit
auch den frieden gewinnen würde ich bin
sehr sehr sicher herr putin hätte so
viel freude an diesem militärischen sieg
wie die amerikaner aber nochmal helga
kugler lehrern jemand richtige haus an
und sie sagen sie können ein haushalt
lasse krieg zu reinigen das ist doch
aber das doch das ganz klare argument im
regal ausgesprochen hat hat der eroberer
von der eroberung und ich sage ist doch
ganz klar was hat der wie kann der
eindringling sich gegen den in dem ding
der reingeht verteidigen in dem fall in
dem der greise und polizei ruft oder in
dem fall haben dem verein führt wird er
ist das ist natürlich die internet
verteidigt da wir müssen ansätzen an dem
was ja in minsk zwei auch vor geht's
nicht weiter schweigen beiden seiten
hatte sich jeder geld sich weil es auch
deswegen gescheitert weil sich die
internationale gemeinschaft weg zu wenig
darum gekümmert hat man muss halt noch
die russen das ist ein problem und
deswegen groß hier und jetzt lassen sie
uns mal was zu dieser these sagen die
und die ukraine sollen sich also erobern
lassen und dann wie sie sagen
unbewaffnet zur wehr setzen gegen den
erobern was ist die alternative was was
machen die dann die setzen sie auf die
straße und die wie gandhi und sagen an
mir kommt jetzt blockieren
alternative ist 3 aber wir haben sie
haben doch als neuer bürgermeister in
düsseldorf wo unrecht einfach unrecht
gelten lassen sondern da hatten sie
polizei und wenn es um recht gab es doch
die polizei eingeschritten es gab ja in
düsseldorf so hoffe ich zumindest und
mein lasst mich zu erinnern keine
rechtsfreien räume in dem sie gesagt
haben jemand irgendwas besetzten wollte
das rathaus beispielsweise durfte das
und durfte einen teil ihres
oberbürgermeister büros besetzen und sie
haben gesagt ich gebe ihnen gern auf den
schreibtischen und damit es bloß keine
gewalt mehr gibt das ist ja ein wirklich
antiquierter ansatz ein intrigen sie
darf nicht weltfremd geld brauchen doch
gar nicht darüber diskutieren dass das
hier auch sie haben gesagt das
berichteten einigkeit geherrscht dass
der eine den krieg nicht gewinnen kann
er sagen sie
doch bestimmt auch die soldaten werden
in kauf nimmt sie würden erstens es für
möglichkeiten das wenn die unseren
channel den krieg gewinnt die russen
kapitulieren und die weiße fahnen line
darum geht es nicht
einigkeit darüber dass ein paar muss ich
mal sagen sie reden generell von waffen
liefern also gar keine waffenlieferung
auch keine sogenannten leichten waffen
schwere schon mal gar nicht der ukraine
krieg gar keine waffen um sich zu wehren
damit diskreditieren sie die haltung der
spd generell auf eine dramatische weise
das heißt nämlich sie sind in wahrheit
mit dem aggressor verbündet und wollen
ihm stopp mal jetzt lassen sie mich mal
was sagen und machen ihm den weg frei
das ganze land zu erobern und dann
können die unbewaffneten sich hinterher
darum kümmern wie sie sich wehren gegen
die besatzung ich glaube die die
aktuelle situation ist schon weit über
ihre these hinaus denn es fehlt nicht
mehr viel dass russland den don was also
die ukraine komplett erobert hat so wie
es schon die krim erobert hat und die
landbrücke von der krummen nach russland
und dann geht es nur noch um die frage
ist jetzt der punkt erreicht an dem ein
waffenstillstand vereinbart wird um
darüber zu verhandeln ob dieser diese
teilung des landes zwischen großen auch
in mehrheitlich russisch besiedelten
gebieten in der ost ukraine und der west
ukraine mit den europäisch orientierten
die künftige grenzlinie zwischen beiden
staaten ist und das geht natürlich nur
wenn die ukraine in der lage ist sich
gegen die russen zu verteidigen sofern
die anstalten machen weiter zu machen
und diese frage stellt sich dann ein ich
glaube sie am ein punkt ist in ihrer
argumentation nicht berücksichtigt das
ist nämlich der dass la die mir putin
eine
mir sagen ziemlich wahnwitzigen
vorstellungen
gehandelt hat die sich als kapitale
thomas roasters putin dachte er wird
insbesondere in den gebieten im don was
wo die russen demo die
russischsprachigen bevölkerung mehrheit
hat als befreier empfang ist selbst so
dass hier immer darauf nicht selbst ein
kapitaler ein kapitaler irrtum der
wahrscheinlich ein ursprung darin dass
wir seit 20 jahren immer nur noch ja
sage und speichellecker um sich
versammelt dem das sagen was er gerne
hört das hat nicht geklappt deswegen sei
er kann den frieden gar nicht mehr
gewinnen er erlebte er völlig
irrsinnigen vorschlag ein bisschen
ähnlich wie die amerikaner als die dem
irak in 1 5 zeichen der freiheit habe
und deswegen glaube ich werde putin ein
großes interesse daran haben dass eine
lösung zustande kommt die ihnen insofern
das gesicht wahren lässt als seine seine
die russische sprachige minderheit oder
in vielen teilen ist es sogar eine
mehrheit eben autonomierechte bekommt
dass sie ihre sprache weiter ausüben
können das nicht gewundert mit einer
geisel an zu rot ist wunderbar
organisiert der geiseln
von einem jahr dass sie immer noch
glauben das sind immer noch das immer
noch spd politiker der meinung sind zu
glauben sie wüssten was wladimir putin
denkt wir haben nun erkannt und das
staatsoberhaupt als ehemaliges
spd-mitglied ist das paradebeispiel
dafür dass offenbar gerade in ihrer
partei eine permanente fehleinschätzung
dessen vorherrscht was wladimir putin zu
tun gedenkt und sie machen den gleichen
fehler schon wieder sie gehen schon
wieder davon aus dass wladimir putin
rational sich verhält wie kommen sie
eigentlich dazu zu glauben die ukraine
könne nicht gewinnen und baby mehr putin
weder gesichtswahrend raus und würde mit
männer die ganze ukraine besetzt
probleme haben dieses land zu befrieden
und überhaupt aber das alles wird wie
kommen sie eigentlich zu diesen ganzen
anderen wo doch erkennbar alles was die
spd oder viele spd-politiker bisher über
wladimir putin gesagt getan und mit ihm
zusammen ausgegangen haben alles völlig
falsch ist die größten fehler hat auch
die cdu gemacht mit einer kanzlerin
merkel und nicht so sehr die spd das zum
einen was mich stört was mich
unglaublich stört in diesen debatten die
ja immer wieder da geführt werden ist
der gratis mut der menschen die alles
anja mensch und jetzt geht es hier
richtig in den krieg jetzt mal los
allesamt ab an die front bitte dann
schickt du deine söhne zuerst das ist
das ist das wäre wohl maltas tonio
kröner nicht wir die ukrainer sagen wir
gehen an die front wird diskutiert doch
keiner dass er an die front will wir
sehen dass die ukraine sich wehren und
fahrzeug zwei rehe und von privaten von
ihrer
entschädigung ein was ich geben treffen
mir und nicht die ukraine es ist
einfacher sprache in der hat doch was er
sich und auch kokolores es geht zunächst
einmal um die frage ganz nüchtern
betrachtet was erreicht man mit einem
solchen konflikt und was kann man
verlieren was man erreicht auf jeden
fall ist die tatsache dass mit jeder
ausgefallenen ernte in der ukraine der
hunger in der welt dramatisch wird auch
das muss berücksichtigt werden bei
diesem gratis und ja ich möchte nur dass
man ein russisches mähdrescher auf die
wiesen fahren das ist doch unmöglich im
erd und auf eine diplomatische sollten
sie am meisten entsetzt mich dass
menschen wie sie auf die russische
propaganda mit atomwaffen
gefallen dies erkennbar für den westen
in den von herrn lang auf dem ich muss
leider hübner auf erdball habe ist die
schlussfolgerung des ernst herzlich und
muss ein spannend war